so you have experience with Magnetic
confinement you have experience with
inertial confinement most of your work
has been a magnetic economy but let's
sort of
um talk about the the the the sexy
recent thing for for a bit of a time
there's been a breakthrough in the news
uh
uh that uh laser-based inertial
confinement was used by Doe's National
ignition facility at the Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory can you
explain this breakthrough that happened
in December yeah
so it goes to the set of criteria that I
talked about before about getting
high energy gain so in the end
what what are we after infusion is that
we we basically assemble this plasma
fuel in some way and we provided a
starting amount of energy think of
lighting the fire and what you want to
do is get back like significant excess
gain from the fact that the fusion is is
making more is releasing the energy so
it's it's like the equivalent of like we
want to have a match a small match light
a fire and then the fire Keeps Us hot
it's like this is very much like that
so as I said we've we've made many of
the and what I mean by we it's like the
fusion Community has pursued aspects of
this through a variety of different
confinement uh methodologies
um is that the
um the key part about what happens
what was the threshold we had never
gotten over before was that if you only
consider the plasma fuel not the not the
total engineering system but just the
plasma fuel itself we had not gotten to
the point yet where basically the size
of the match was was smaller than the
amount of energy that we got from the
fusion is there a good term for when the
output is greater than the input yes yes
it there is well there's several special
definitions of this so one of them is
that if you if you like in a fire if you
light a match and you have it there and
it's an infinitesimal amount of energy
compared to what you're getting out of
the fire we call this ignition which
makes sense right this is like what the
what our own sign is as well too so that
that was not ignition in that sense as
well too so what we call this the
scientific what the one that we I just
talked about which is for for some
instance when I get enough Fusion energy
released compared to the size of the
match we call this sign to Civic break
even break even break even and it's
because you've gotten past the fact that
this is Unity now at this point what is
a fusion gain or as using the notation Q
from the paper overview of the spark
Tacoma before talk using just the same
kind of terms yeah actually so the
technical term is Q capital Q
people actually use cubes we actually
use capital Q or sometimes it's called Q
is taken Q sub P or something like this
okay okay so this is which which means
what what it means is that it's in the
plasma so all we're considering is is
the energy balance or a gain that comes
from the plasma itself we're not
considering the Technologies which are
around it which are providing the
containment and so forth so why why the
excitement and so well because for one
reason it's a rather Sim it's a rather
simple threshold to get over to
understand that you're getting more
energy out from the fusion even the
theoretical sense than you were from the
you know from the starting match do you
mean consent actually simple it's
conceptually simple that you get past
one that everyone under like when you're
less than one that's much less
interesting than getting past one
because that's a really big you started
to get fast but it's it's really it
really is a scientific threshold because
what QP actually
um denotes is the relative amount of
self-heating that's happening in the in
the plasma so what I mean by this is
that in the end in these systems for and
what what you want is something that
where the the relative amount of of
heating which is keeping the fuel hot is
dominated by from the fusion reactions
themselves and and so it becomes it's
it's sort of like thinking like a
bonfire is a lot more interesting
physically than just holding a blow
torch to a wet log right there's a lot
more Dynamics it's a lot more
self-evolved and so forth and what we're
excited as a scientists is that it's
clear that the the in that experiment
that they actually got to a point where
the fusion reactions themselves were
actually altering the state of the
plasma
I was like wow I mean we'd seen it in
glimpses before in magnetic confinement
at relatively small levels but
apparently it seems like in this
experiment it's likely to be a dominant
dominated by self-heating that's a very
important that's a very interesting that
makes it a self-sustaining type of it's
more self-sustaining it's more
self-referential system uh in in a sense
and it sort of self-evolves in a way
again it's not that it's going to evolve
to a dangerous State it's just that we
want to see what happens when when the
fusion is the dominant heating source
and we'll talk about that but so there's
also another element which is the
inertial confinement
uh laser-based initial confinement is
kind of a little bit of another dog okay
so a lot of the broad nuclear fusion
Community has been focused on magnetic
confinement can you explain just how
laser-based inertial confinement works
so it says uh 192 laser beams were
aligned on a deuterium tritium DT Target
smaller than a p yes uh this is like
actually yeah okay well you know it
depends not all P's are made the same
but uh this is like throwing a perfect
strike in baseball from a pitch this is
like a journalist wrote this I think
this is like oh no it's not a journalist
it's do yeah yeah we try to use all
these analogies this is like throwing a
perfect strike in baseball from a
pitcher's Mount 350 miles away from the
plate there you go Department of energy
the United States Department of energy
wrote this
okay so can you explain interesting what
the what the lasers what what actually
happens yeah actually there's usually
Mass confusion about this so
um so what's going on in this form over
so the fuel
is is is delivered in a discrete the
Fusion fuel the deuterium and tritium is
in a discrete spherical it's more like a
BB let's call it a BB so it's a small
one and all the fuel that you're going
to try to to burn is basically there
okay and it's about that size so what's
hap so how are you going to get and it's
that literally it's like at 20 degrees
above absolute zero because the
deuterium and tritium are kept in in a
liquid in a solid state so the fuel is
injected not as a gas as a solid it's
actually and it's very and these are
particular experiments they can
introduce one of these you know these
targets once per day approximately
something like that because it's very
it's very it's kind of amazing
technology actually that I know some of
the people that worked on this uh back
in the is
um they actually make these things out
of BB size of this frozen fuel it's
actually a cryogenic temperatures and
they're almost like Smooth to the atom
level I mean they're amazing pieces of
Technology
so what you do in the end is think what
you have is a spherical
assembly of this fuel like a ball and
what what is the purpose of the lasers
the purpose of the lasers is to provide
Optical energy to the very outside of
this and what happens is the that energy
is absorbed because it's it's in the
solid phase of matter so it's absorbed
really in the surface and then what
happens is that when it's absorbed in
something called the ablator what does
that mean it means it goes instantly
from the solid phase to the gas phase so
it becomes like a rocket engine and but
you hit it like very uniformly so all
there's like rocket engines coming off
this surface think of like an asteroid
almost where there's like rockets coming
off and all this thing so what does that
do what does a rocket do it actually
pushes by Newton's Laws right it pushes
the other thing on the other side of it
equal and opposite reaction it pushes it
in so what it does is it that the lasers
actually don't Heat this is what was
confusing people think the laser oh
we're gonna get it to 100 million
degrees in fact you want the exact
opposite of this what you want to do is
get essentially a rocket going out like
this and then what happens is that the
sphere like and this is happening in a
billionth of a second or less actually
this rapidly that that Force like so
rapidly compresses the fuel then what
happens is that you're squeezing down on
it and and and you know it's like what
was the CBB that's bad actually B I
should have started with a basketball
basket goes from like a basketball down
to something like like this and then
billionth of a second
and when that when that happens I mean
you scale that in your mind so when that
happens and in this this comes from
almost from classical physics so there's
some Quantum in it as well too but
basically if you can do this
um like very uniformly and so-called
adiabatically like you're not actually
heating the fuel what happens is you get
adiabatic compression such that the very
center of this thing all of a sudden
just spikes up in temperature because
it's it's it's actually done so fast so
why is it called inertial Fusion it's
because you're doing this on such fast
time scales that the inertia of the hot
fuel basically is still finite so it
can't like push itself apart before the
fusion happens
oh wow so how do you make it so how do
you make it so fast this is why you use
lasers because you're applying this
energy in very very short periods of
time like under a fraction of a
billionth of a second and so basically
that and then the force which is coming
from this comes from the energy of the
lasers which which is basically the
rocket action which does the compression
which is the force is the inward facing
Force is is that is that increasing the
temperature no exponential you want to
keep the fuel cold
and then and just literally just ideally
compress it and then in something which
is at the very center of that compressed
sphere because you've compressed it so
rapidly the laws of physics basically
require for it to increase in
temperature so the the effect is like if
you know the thing so adiabatic cooling
were actually fairly familiar with if
you take a spray can right and you push
the button when it when it rapidly
expands it cools this is the nature of a
lot of cooling technology we use
actually well the opposite is true that
if you would take all of those particles
and jam them together very fast back in
they want to heat up
and that's what happens and then what
happens is you you basically have this
very cold compressed set of Fusion fuel
and at the center of this it goes to
this 100 million degrees Celsius and so
if it gets to that 100 million degrees
Celsius the Fusion fuel starts to burn
and when that Fusion fuel starts to burn
it wants to heat up the other cold fuel
around it and it just basically
propagates out so fast that what you
would do ideally you would actually burn
in a fusion sense most of the fuel
that's in the pellet so this was very
exciting because what they had done was
they it's clear that they propagated
this they got this what they call a hot
spot and in fact that this heating can
propagate it out into the fuel
um and that's that's the science behind
inertial Fusion so the idea behind a
reactor is based on this kind of
inertial uh uh confinement is that you
would what have a new BB every like 10
times a second or something like and
then there's some kind of yeah so
there's a incredible device that you
kind of implied that kind of has to
create one of those BBS that did so you
have to make the BBS very fast there's
reports on this but about what what does
it mean you know the starting point is
can you make this game
so this was a scientific achievement
primarily because and the rest is just
engineering no no no the rest is
incredibly complicated engineering well
in fact there's still physics hurdles to
overcome so so where does this come from
and it's actually because if you want to
make an energy source out of this
um this had a gain of around 1.5 that
namely the Fusion Energy was
approximately was 1.5 times the the
laser input energy okay this is a fairly
significant threshold however from the
from the science of what I just told you
is that there's two fundamental
efficiencies which come into it which
really come from physics really one of
them is hydrodynamic efficiency what I
mean by this is that it's a rocket so
this just has a fundamental
efficiency built into it which comes out
to orders of like 10 percent so this
means is that your your ability to do
work on the system is just limited by
that okay and then the other one is the
efficiency of laser systems themselves
which if their wall plug efficiency is
10 you've done spectacularly well in
fact the wall plug efficiency of the
ones using that experiments are like
more like one percent right so when you
go through all of this the approximate
you know place that you're ordering this
is for for fusion power plant would be a
gain of a hundred not 1.5 so you still
you know and hopefully we see
experiments that keep climbing up
towards higher and higher gain but then
the whole fusion power plant is a
totally different thing so it's not one
it's not one BB and one laser pulse per
day it's like ten times five or ten
times per second like
that right so you're doing it there and
then then and then comes the other
aspects so it's making the targets
delivering them being able to repeatedly
get them to burn and then we haven't
even talked about like how do you then
get the Fusion Energy out which is
mainly because these things are
basically micro you know implosions
which are occurring so this energy is
coming out to some medium on the outside
that you've got to figure out how to
extract the energy out of this thing how
do you convert that energy to
electricity so in the end you have to
basically convert it into heat in some
way so most of the pro what you in the
end what Fusion makes mostly is like
very energetic particles from the fusion
reaction so you have to slow those down
in some way and then make heat out of it
so basically the conversion of the
kinetic energy of the particles into
heating some engineered material that's
on the outside of this and that's from a
physics perspective is a somewhat solved
problem but from an engineering is is
still it's still yeah physics I can draw
the I can show you all the equations
that tell you about how it slows down
and converts kinetic energy into heat
and then what that heat means you know
you can write out like an ideal thermal
cycle like a carnosis so the physics of
that yeah great the integrated
engineering of this is a whole other
thing a last case of maybe talk about
the difference between a natural
magnetic uh but first we'll talk about
magnetic but let me just link on this
breakthrough you know it's nice to have
exciting things but
in a deep human sense there's no
competition in science and engineering
or like you said we we're broad first of
all we are a Humanity all together and
you talk about this it's a bunch of
countries collaborating it's it's really
exciting uh there's a nuclear fusion
Community broadly but then there's also
MIT there's colors and logos and it's
exciting and there's a that you uh you
have uh friends and colleagues here that
that work extremely hard and done some
incredible stuff is there some sort of
how do you feel seeing somebody else uh
get a breakthrough in a using a
different technology is that exciting uh
is this does the competitive fire uh get
uh all of the above I mean I mean the
ignition you know I have so uh you know
to you know just to wave the wave the
flag a little bit so MIT was a central
player in in this in this accomplishment
um interesting I would say it showed our
two some of our two best traits so one
of them was that the
like how do you know that this happened
this measurement right so one of the
ways to do this is if I told you is that
the in the DT Fusion what it actually
the product that comes out is helium we
call an alpha but it's helium
um and a free Neutron right so the
neutron contains 80 percent of the
fusion of the energy released by the
fusion reaction and it also because it
has lack it lacks a charge it basically
tends to just escape and go flying out
so this is what we would use eventually
for
that's mostly what Fusion Energy would
be but so what um my my colleagues my
scientific colleagues at uh at the plaza
science Infusion Center built were
extraordinary measurement tools of being
able to see the exact details of not
only the number of neutrons that were
coming out but actually what energy that
they're at and by looking at that that
configuration it reveals enormous I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna scoop them
because they need to publish the paper
but it it reveals enormous amounts of
scientific information about what's
happening in that process that I just
described so exciting I mean and I there
you know I have colleagues there that
have worked like for 30 years on this
for that moment of course you're excited
for them I mean and this one of those
like there's there's nothing it's hard
to describe to people who aren't they
haven't it's like almost addicting to be
a scientist when you get to be at the
Forefront of research of anything like
when you see like an actual discovery of
some kind and you're looking at it
particularly when you're are the person
who did it right and you go no human
being has ever seen this or understood
this it's like it's pretty thrilling
right so even even in proxy it's it's
incredibly thrilling to see this it's
not I don't know it's rivalry or
jealousy it's like I can tell you
already Fusion is really hard so
anything that keeps pushing the needle
forward is a good thing but we also have
to be realistic about what it means you
know to making a Fusion Energy System
that's that's and then but that's the
fun I mean these are the are still the
early steps you maybe you can say the
early leaps uh
so let's talk about the magnetic
confinement uh what is how does uh
magnetic confinement work what's the
takamak uh yeah how does it all work so
go back to that so why inertial
confinement works on the same principle
that a star works so like what is the
confinement mechanism in the star is
gravity
because it's it's it's it's its own
inertia of the something the size of the
sun basically pushes a literally a force
by gravity against the center so the
center is is very very hot 20 million
degrees and literally outside the sun
it's essentially zero because it's
vacuum of space how the hell does that
do that it does that by and is out of
through like why doesn't just leak all
of its heat it doesn't leak its heat
because it all held together by the fact
that it can't escape because of its own
gravity so this is why the fusion
happens in the center of the Tsar like
we think of the surface of the Sun as
being hot that's the coldest part of the
star so over our own sudden this is
about in 5500 degrees a beautiful
Symmetry by the way it's like so how do
we know all this because we can't of
course see directly into the interior of
the Sun by knowing the volume and the
temperature of the surface of the Sun
you know exactly how much power it's
putting out and by this you you know
that this is coming from Fusion
reactions occurring at exactly the same
rate in the middle of of the Sun
is it possible as a small tangent to
build uh an inertial confinement system
like the sun is it possible to create a
sun it is of course possible to make a
sun although he doesn't have stars but
it is not impossible on Earth because
for the simple reason that it takes the
gravitational force is extremely weak
and so it takes something like the size
of a star to make fusion occur in the
center well I I didn't mean on Earth I
mean if you had to build like a second
sun how'd you do it you can't there's
not enough hydrogen around yeah so the
the limiting factor is the the just the
hydrogen yeah I mean the the forces that
an energy that it takes to assemble that
is just mind-boggling all right so we
would do that to be continued you have
to be continued